le politologue stéphane rozès président
de cap et enseignant à sciences po
bonjour stéphane rozès merci de répondre
à nos questions à la veille du
déconfinement quel bilan est ce que vous
faites de cette mise sous cloche sur le
plan politique vous voulez dire bilan du
confinement sur le clan politique qui
aurait énormément de choses à dire du
point de vue des individus de
confinement entraînant que le possible
se restreint ils réaménagent de
souhaitable dans leur rapport à la vie à
ce qui est important ou travaillent à la
société à la question environnementale à
la triste matic qui vient au rapport à
nous et avec la proximité la question de
la souveraineté industrielle question la
souveraineté nationale la question
démocratique bref durant toutes ces
journées l'individu stopper comme un
arrêt sur image dans sa course
quotidienne je dirai au travail à la
consommation à la vie à une occasion de
réfléchir
et puis il ya le déconfinement qui
arrive et là ce sont les inquiétudes au
fond les individus ont le sentiment
qu'ils doivent choisir quand ils le
peuvent
entre labour c est la vie man truck ce
qu'a dit le premier ministre l'impératif
senneterre et la nécessité bon les
individus et la france de reprendre une
activité
donc ça c'est du point de vue des
individus du point de vue des
institutions et de la communication dès
le départ les français sont frappés par
le niveau d'impréparation de notre
système de santé du sommet de l'état du
retard votre chronologie l'a bien
indiqué du retard à l'allumage en des
politiques invités chez un beau
confrères bfm business dès le 24 février
je m'étonnais du fait que polarisée par
la crise sociale des retraites
l'exécutif ne prennent pas la mesure de
ce qui arrivait je m'étonnais vous
l'avez dit du fait qu'on puisse
maintenir
des élections municipales alors que tout
le pays devrait être c'est à dire est en
ligne sur la question du principe de
précaution
au fond les français ont le sentiment
que le principe de précaution qui
devrait prévaloir même quand des
scientifiques ne sont pas d'accord entre
eux a été tout ces dernières années en
début de crise
remplacé par un autre principe qui est
le principe comptable un principe ou au
fond la pensée c'est une pensée de
gestionnaires pas une pensée de
gouvernance donc l'anticipation qu'on
attend du politique décisif dans sa pays
comme la france la france est le pays au
monde la question de l'état tout tourne
autour de d'état dans d'autres pays en
allemagne ce sont les länder en italie
ce sont des sites et à des régions
chaque pays a son ingénieur son âme et
amener différemment sa guerre contre l'
tandis le être aplanies pour revenir sur
la france vous qui êtes un spécialiste
en communication quelles sont les
erreurs du gouvernement et surtout
quelle sera sa réaction la réaction du
couple exécutif certaines rumeurs ont
évoqué ces derniers temps un possible
nouveau premier ministre
je ne sais pas si je suis vraiment un
expert en communication et je sais même
pas si la communication existent si on
la conçoit comme séparer de l'action
fortiori lors d'une crise sanitaire ou
la communication quel prix sanitaire
doit conduire au bon comportement des
citoyens
la communication n'est pas autonome du
fonds les couacs de communication dont
vous avez parlé ont des causes profondes
institutionnels le président semble dire
le souhaitable premier lit me semble
dire le réel les contraintes ce qu'il
faut faire
d'où une première des connection mais ça
veut dire que au sommet de l'état
les choses n'ont pas été pensés en mode
projet à 360° de sorte qu'il y ait une
cohérence dans ce que l'on dit et ce que
l'on fait
et donc ça c'est un principe de base de
la communication
bien sûr mais derrière ça il ya des
questions plus profond qui se font au
sommet de l'état depuis les gilets
jaunes qu'il faut bien comprendre le
président est élu par la nation il s'est
fait élire comme année aux gones appart
et puis les politiques français sont
insérés dans des logiques et politiques
européennes qui font que il ya d'un côté
les vidz est dans une posture néo
bonaparte qui gère la parole la
communication et puis le nôtre il ya des
politiques concrètes qui sont une part
non pas du tout une orientation néo
bonapartiste mais orléaniste c'est
mâtinant c'est bercy
ce sont les comptes c'est ce que
emmanuel maintenant avait appelé
autrefois le fétichisme budgétaire et
donc depuis le gilet jaune au sommet de
l'état il ya une discussion sur kelly
létale la france qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que la france qu'est ce que l'état de la
france
comment réformer selon quelles modalités
et donc ces débats au sommet de l'état
où on ferait qui a le sentiment que
alors que le président devrait tenir
ensemble le souhaitable et le possible
dans sa communication et en sorte de
répartition des rôles par exemple quand
le président a annoncé déconfinement de
demain le 11 mai il ne prévient
quasiment par le gouvernement et du coup
dès le lendemain il ya des couacs
parce que les gens découvrent et la
décision du 11 mai les modalités n'ont
pas été pensés en mode projet donc en un
mot la communication n'est que la
déclinaison de stratégie de vision quand
il y en a hélas n'y en a pas eu
et d'action mais qui doivent être
normalement penser ensemble et en
cohérence
hessel n'a pas été cas merci stéphane
rozès d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
cap
enseignant à sciences po également
acheter